es ist die frage der woche meine damen
und herren gibt es erste signale der
hoffnung im ukraine krieg ziehen sich
die russen teilweise zurück oder ist das
wieder ein täuschungsmanöver ich würde
mein geld auf letzteres setzen wenn ich
es nicht zum gas kaufen bräuchte gas
wird immer teurer und wenn putin diese
woche sagt der hahn bleibt vorläufig auf
selbst wenn ihre euro zahlt bedeutet das
gar nichts man kann ihm nicht trauen
deshalb bereiten wir uns völlig zu recht
auf den worst case vor und jeder von uns
kann seinen beitrag leisten getreu dem
alten motto ich kenne keine parteien
mehr ich kenne nur noch energiesparer
danke für diese gemeinsame nationale
kraftanstrengung jede kilowattstunde
energie die wir einsparen ist eine
kilowattstunde energie die putin schadet
jeder einzelne ist gefragt ich zum
beispiel habe schon einige meiner
whirlpools vorübergehend abgestellt dass
putin völlige zustimmung am
energiesparen führt kein weg vorbei und
zum glück kann ich nur sagen ist diese
sendung längst autark denn wir arbeiten
hier im studio nur noch mit
regenerativen scheiß rassist jetzt
wieder mit dem licht mein gott schreien
ja jede kilowattstunde zählt sorry
geht doch erneuerbare olaf bei putins
propaganda dauerfeuer kann man
jedenfalls gar nichts mehr glauben ist
ja so gespräche über eine waffenruhe
während weiter bomben und raketen auf
wohnhäuser fallen was wäre am ende
erreichen also außer der kompletten
zerstörung des landes dass er angeblich
befreit ich dachte ja immer er arbeitet
an der sowjetunion 2.0 jetzt stellt sich
plötzlich raus er führt einen kultur
krieg beziehungsweise cancel kalter
krieg denn der mond mini lee vor einiger
zeit wurde joanne k rowling deren
harry-potter-bücher sich millionenfach
auf der ganzen welt verkaufen gecancelt
weil sie die vertreter der sogenannten
gender freiheit verärgert hat heute
versuchen sie ein ganzes land mit einer
tausendjährigen geschichte zu canceln
unser volk nach nalut
vorsicht mit tausendjähriger geschichte
an dem slogan hält jemand anders die
rechte legal wladimir potter will also
die ukraine wegzaubern und er kämpft
gegen das gender sternchen also so
verstehe ich zumindest putin während der
ukrainische präsident die ultimative
ehrung erfährt der kriege in der ukraine
erreicht mittlerweile sogar die
spielzeugindustrie die wird kreativ ein
hersteller von lego bausteinen in den
usa erweiterte nämlich nun sein angebot
um eine miniatur figur des ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky und um ein
spielzeug molotow-cocktail mama haben
wir noch leere flaschen und benzin
pädagogisch zweifelhafter spielzeug ja
aber der see lenski ist super geworden
oder finde ich echt angeblich planen sie
schon den lego putin und zwar als rosa
prinzessin beziehungsweise transport ihn
sehr schön auch in dieser woche hat der
gender krieger wieder mit unserem
bundeskanzler telefoniert wegen der
gasrechnung mit olaf scholz der sich
aktuell auf dem spiegel titel
wiederfindet anders gesehen krieger
wider willen es ging seitenweise um
seine stärken und schwächen um angeblich
mangelnde führung wir erinnern uns noch
bis gefühlt drei minuten vor einmarsch
hat der mann an nordstream zwei
festgehalten und bei waffenlieferungen
an die ukraine sehr lange gezögert sehr
lange da ist die frage nach führung
schon legitim oder ich finde das
ziemlich schnell und ziemlich viel
führung und wenn jemand das anders sieht
dann
ich hatte meinen liefern haben gestatte
ich das sehr gerne weil das zur
demokratie und zur meinungsfreiheit dazu
gehört aber es ist nicht realistisch
dass das eine seriöse haltung ist wie
gütig kritik an ihm es gestattet danke
dafür es ist aber zitat nicht
realistisch dass sie seriös ist wahr
dass überhaupt ein deutscher satz ich
bin mir nicht sicher wir fassen zusammen
der kanzler findet dass der kanzler
alles richtig macht
erzählt bei anne will er sei schon als
finanzminister für einen größeren wert
gewesen und als hamburger bürgermeister
für flüssiggas terminals verstehe sie
scholz hat also im prinzip immer schon
gewusst was man hätte machen müssen und
es dann zu machen wegen anderer termine
oder wegen merke keine ahnung
filmreife argumentation jedenfalls
sehen sie olaf scholz salzburg scholz
bei anne will in vancouver bleiben denn
niemand war jemals so gut vorbereitet
und wir haben pläne die wir lange in der
schublade hatten und für die ich mich
allerdings sehr lange schon eingesetzt
habe dass sie aus dieser schublade
heraus kommen jetzt aktiv geschaltet und
deshalb haben wir uns so gut vorbereitet
und deshalb arbeiten wir jetzt mit dem
schnellsten tempo das überhaupt möglich
ist und das ist alles sehr besprochen
sehr vorbereitet diese entscheidung
haben wir getroffen und großer
vorbereitung und großen plan er hat
einfach den größten plan und weiß alles
vorher zum beispiel dass dieser
fahrstuhl nach oben fahren bögl denn er
hat auf 9 gedrückt auf seinem
schreibtisch liegen geheime akten mit
allen lotto zahlen die in diesem jahr
noch kommen und alle mördern bei
inspector barnaby olaf scholz der mann
der zuviel wusste und zwar immer schon
vorher
wahnsinn der best informierte kanzler
aller zeiten wirklich
sekunde muss ich kurz ran hallo herr
scholz ok verstehe alles klar gut zu
wissen der scheinwerfer danke für den
tipp dankeschön
voll nett von ihnen oder was übrigens
stimmt seine berühmte 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr rede war tatsächlich eine
zeitenwende können sie alles nachlesen
in der neuen zeiten wenn die nur seitdem
ist der zeitenwende spirit halt so ein
bisschen verflogen muss man sagen
beispiel öl und gas embargo
wirtschaftsexperten streiten noch über
die genauen folgen aber fakt ist wir
stützen jeden tag mit 100 millionen
weiter das mörderische system putin
punkt und ich finde ja wenn eine
beziehung ist zerrüttet ist muss man
natürlich derjenige sein der zuerst
schluss macht ist so logisch vor allem
wenn einen der partner schon seit jahren
verwöhnt
uns habe ich nie verstanden
womit wollt ihr eigentlich heizen unser
gas wollt mir nicht atomenergie auch
nicht wollt ihr mit holz heizen und
selbst dafür werdet ihr nach sibirien
fahren müssen
[Applaus]
frechheit zur not verfolgende thüringen
besteht nur aus wald ich meine klar
sanktionen führen immer zu reaktionen
für mich war es die schockmeldung der
woche hat es gesehen
einreisebeschränkungen für deutsche
bürger in russland das ist hart zumal
die reisebranche in der korona zeit weiß
gott genug gelitten hat und jetzt platzt
auch noch der ganze russland tourismus
alle ihre gebuchten russland reisen
fallen diesen sommer leider aber was ist
mit meinen drei wochen im club med
wladiwostok wie gesagt ein reiseverbot
gut dann buchung auf casillas liebe
kunden der veranstalter bietet ihnen als
ausgleich die malediven an
gute frage einreisebeschränkungen für
uns kann man doch nicht machen diese
woche melden us geheimdienste putins
berater trauen sich nicht mehr in die
wahrheit zu sagen kein problem hörte sie
eben von carolin kebekus
carolin kebekus freedom altare los im
kreml
haye klar weiß ich mich schon immer
gefragt warum hast du eigentlich so
großen tisch tor so gar keine freunde
ich will dich ja nicht aufhalten du hast
ja ein angriffskrieg zu führen bzw wie
sagst du immer eine spezialoperation zur
beseitigung gefährlicher waisenhäuser
ach ja richtig mit dem botox gesicht
keine her gar nicht mehr lachen
putin pass auf folgendes
einreiseverbot für deutsche großer
fehler denn genauso wenig wie die russen
gibt die deutschen und was immer noch
tierisch viele fans bei uns so krank
dass ist und ich sage diese leute müssen
weiter urlaub in russland machen dürfen
am besten möglichst lange ich sag nur
querdenker schon mal gehört querdenker
die lieben dich
die krieg wir wollen nicht
[Musik]
die geduld
halte deine groupies möchte mal auch
nicht geschenkt haben
jedenfalls wäre es super nice von dir
wenn du uns diese ganzen quer vögel
abnehmen würde denn ganz ehrlich gesagt
wir wollen die nicht mehr die sind auch
vielleicht die gehen viel spazieren und
so die märkte kaum so will habe ich noch
auf meine abschiede ich meine urlaub in
russland liste gerd schröder klar die
hälfte der linkspartei klar plus warte
mal
komplette als de kann das sein gutes
essen und das ist sein gutes recht in
diesem fall geben wie so oft in der
geschichte dass der angreifer nicht der
eigentliche aggressor ist
stimmt die komplette afd und sekunde
besteht hier noch
richard david precht nie wirklich dem
musst du rein lassen das ist ein super
typ erstens der ist wunderschön zweiter
der sagt in seinem podcast neuerdings
ganz viele sachen die würden die es
super gefallen natürlich hat die ukraine
ein recht aus selbstvertrauen und ein
recht auf selbstverteidigung aber auch
die pflicht zur klugheit 1 zu sehen weil
man sich ergeben muss
richard david precht bei dem krieg ich
spontan achtung precht durchfall
aus dem warmen studio anderen erklären
wann sie aufzugeben haben und er ist
ausgebildeter philosophen hat das heißt
er könnte also sofort hier in moskau
taxifahren also lass dir mal meine liste
da und dann brauchst du denn allen flug
nach russland wenn mir gern nur hinflug
und denkt an wenn du dem asyl kippst
wirkt sich das später vielleicht positiv
auf sein urteil enden
ja meine fresse jetzt lag halt mal so
ist das eben eine demokratie ich kann
sagen was ich will sogar das wort krieg
krieg du führst im krieg alter
kriegsverbrecher und was willst jetzt
dagegen machen original nichts dagegen
machen
ok danke das aber ganz lieben
carolin kebekus redete mal tacheles im
kreml
carolin kebekus aber ich kann sie
beruhigen meine damen und herren es gibt
auch noch andere schlechte nachrichten
alles hängt mit allem zusammen weil das
sonnenblumenöl knapp wird droht uns
jetzt die mega katastrophe die pommes
werden knapp
ach ja und die inflationsrate ist so
hoch wie seit 40 jahren nicht mehr 7,3
prozent im märz liegt natürlich vor
allem an den energiepreisen logisch ein
durchschnittlicher deutscher haushalt
wird dieses jahr mindestens 2000 euro
mehr alleine für gas ausgeben ist irre
mensch hätten wir doch schon mehr
windräder und solardächer oder
poetischer formuliert man kann den wind
nicht klauen die sonne gehört niemandem
auf startnummer 3 der robert mit man
kann den wind nicht klauen bitte nicht
wieder wählen ist quatsch wenn er kann
ja nichts dafür
wir haben es uns als gesellschaft zu
muckelig gemacht in der abhängigkeit
beschützt von den amis bereits von putin
zumindest solange sein gas noch fließt
diese woche gab es ja den großen
showdown knallharter ansage aus moskau
ab freitag wird die gasrechnung nur noch
im rudel bezahlt sonst gashahn zu dann
hieß es plötzlich okay euro und dollar
gehen irgendwie auch ja wie denn jetzt
euro erlaubt aber auf einem rubel konto
und war das jetzt ein peinlicher
rückzieher von graf dracula oder doch
nur seine neueste finte und was wenn er
demnächst wirklich ernst macht um für
diese situation vorbereitet zu sein habe
ich heute morgen die frühwarn stufe nach
der gas verordnung ausgerufen so jetzt
haben wir den salat freunde früh
warnstufe nach der gas verordnung was
ist das da ist eigentlich ganz einfach
es gibt insgesamt drei stufen habe ich
gelernt jetzt in der ersten stufe ist
monitoring- angesagt das heißt übersetzt
ein krisenstab beobachtet unsere
gasspeicher
dann kommt stufe zwei die sogenannte
alarmstufe die geht so
alarm halt wo man aber noch sagt das
kriegt der markt irgendwie alleine hin
gefolgt von stufe 3 der notfall stufe
das wäre diese hier
[Applaus]
soweit klar geworden oder dann erst in
der letzten stufe greift der staat ein
und entscheidet wer noch gas bekommt
privathaushalte krankenhäuser oder
schulen würden weiter beliefert heißt es
für die industrie kam es aber dicke
möglicherweise vor allem für die
chemische und wenn es firma wie basf den
betrieb einstellt hängen da sich andere
branchen dran ja so läuft das leider in
unserer globalen vernetzten welt
bedeutet man müsste was dann wohl folgt
sozial noch viel stärker abfedern und
ganz wichtig die sogenannten notfall
pläne umsetzen kann ich meinen guten
hören die bitte von den habig ist eine
der wir uns als fdp aber vollumfänglich
anschließen und das ist zur not zum
pullover zu greifen zu hause die bitte
von herrn habeck und der fdp geht mir
entschieden zu weit pullover kann ich
auch eine fleecejacke nein schade wie
wäre es dann zusätzlich mit tempolimit
das will die fdp nicht kann man nix
machen kann man nix machen olaf schubert
meine damen und herren arbeitet
neuerdings in der heute-show
wirtschaftsredaktion weil er wegen der
inflation mehr geld braucht urlaub schön
dass du da bist die höchste
inflationsrate seit über 40 jahren was
können wir verbraucher da machen außer
anderes gesicht
du wirst gesicht ich habe jetzt sogar
zwei doofe gesichter gesehen meine
kinder weil man da merkt wie sich
wirklich die dinge verschieden ja also
meine tochter die bekamen vor paar
jahren zum achtzehnten geburtstag ein
auto mein so hunden jetzt wird das
gleiche geld der bekommt zehn hinter
benzin aber was mir eigentlich viel mehr
sorge bereitet das ist die neue knöpfe
an lebensmitteln ja es werden
tatsächlich wieder speiseöl und mehl
gehortet ja und ich versuche jetzt
natürlich so schnell wie möglich so viel
wie möglich da irgendwie hinzukriegen er
hat bevor die ganzen asozialen
hamsterkäufe wieder anfangen das klingt
vernünftig wie stehst du persönlich zum
vorübergehenden tempolimit es bleibt
glaube ich die frage muss man alles
reglementieren und mit paragraphen und
irgendwie pipapo ich meine man muss doch
auch mal auf eigenverantwortung setzen
und irgendwie den menschen auch mal was
zutrauen ja durch gesunden
menschenverstand habe ich zum beispiel
geschafft ich habe meinen
benzinverbrauch um 50 prozent reduziert
ja also ich mach so ich fahre jetzt nur
noch hin ich habe mich dezentralisiert
also dort ist das neue hier so viele
menschen unterwegs und wie die fahren
jeden tag hier zwischen chemnitz und
gütersloh hin und her das ist ja quatsch
ich meine da viel effektiver einen von
beiden städten zu schließen oder in dem
fall sogar beide also das wäre in wien
durch louis blues wir sind alle zum
energie sparen aufgerufen ich sprach
schon drüber beim heizen beim strom hast
du dann noch irgendwelche tipps im petto
es gibt ja so die diese klassiker die
immer gelten die kenne ich noch von
meiner oma oder ich habe ja zwei kommen
die eine immer so gesagt ja eben das
klassische dass man eben
was weiß ich mit kaltem wasser kocht ja
oder dass man eben nur lauwarm ein
frosted unter dass man im dunkeln
schläft da gibt es 1000 keine dinge
effektiv sparen kann man aber wirklich
bei der heizung ein grad weniger
raumtemperatur heißt sechs prozent
energieeinsparung ja das ist kein
quatsch das stimmt tatsächlich und wenn
man das mal weiter denkt also wenn ich
die raumtemperatur um 20 grad senken
sprich 120 prozent energie er hat dann
kriege ich geld von den stadtwerken und
bei mir ist es allerdings dahingehend
problematisch dass ich wirklich eine
sehr große wohnung habe ich will jetzt
nicht jammern aber ich habe die in den
letzten jahren schon kaum waren direkt
vor allen dingen den nordflügel und
jetzt im letzten winter also das ging so
weit dass ich wirklich den halben winter
in der karibik verbringen musste das so
als tipp für die leute daheim nicht weiß
das natürlich
schwierig dann gerade für eltern von
schulpflichtigen kindern hat die kinder
sind dann halt die ganze zeit alleine in
der kalten wohnung aber ich meine die
freiheit pvv zu gehören ich wollte es ja
auch nicht anders oder vielen dank du
kannst wieder auf den generator und das
gesamte team führt also gleich mehrere
kriege meine damen und herren den
energie krieg den richtigen gegen die
menschen in der ukraine und wie heute
schon gesagt den krieg gegen länder
deswegen ist dieses berühmte internet
meme in russland verboten wirklich war
dabei steht es ihm eigentlich ganz gut
oder und in deutschen feuilletons wird
seit tagen wild diskutiert was in diesen
zeiten richtige männer sind da steht
ausgerechnet der krieg plötzlich fürs
comeback des toxischen mannes der
angeblich wieder gebraucht wird
friedemann weise ist mindestens
irritiert
ratschläge in die fresse mit friedemann
weise
ich bin komplett verwirrt seit jahren
versuche ich mich von toxischer
männlichkeit zu befreien ich war beim
lachyoga beim wein yoga ich gehe zum
vater kind ballett und macht beim kita
fest den waffelstand im einhorn kostüm
ich wollte alles richtig machen und
jetzt muss ich mir von dieser frau
anhören dass ich durch mein verhalten
deutschland das rückgrat gebrochen habe
und ich bin ja nicht der einzige mann
der sich fragen stellt was bedeutet es
ein wahrer mann zu sehen musst du einen
drachen dafür tun musst du doch wie vor
kommen durchtrainiert sein musst du
dafür ein lamborghini fahren was dazu
nötig um ein wahrer mann zu sehen genau
was ist dazu nötig um ein wahrer mann zu
sein ich würde sagen vielleicht weniger
toxische seite mehr weibliche seite du
hast genug der weiblichen seite in dir
du hast mehr als genug da versucht nicht
noch mehr zu haben
was
das gehört jetzt zum mannsein
verantwortung macht wencke hab ich denn
überhaupt noch fragen bei denen beide
mit großer macht kommt große
verantwortung und wenn man diese
verantwortung oder diese moralische
verantwortung nicht übernehmen möchte
ist es so dass die frau unter umständen
eingeht
nein dann habe ich den zuletzt meine
frau begossen und die verwirrung fängt
ja immer früh ran letzte woche hat die
sendung mit der maus erklärt was eine
trans personen ist sonntagmorgens völlig
verantwortungslos das verstört doch die
zuschauer total also nicht die kinder
die ganz verstanden aber die arbeit
journalisten die um die zeit besoffen
aus dem klub nach hause kommt julian
reichelt drehte völlig frei und
twitterte irgendwas von der zwangs maus
so nannte er wahrscheinlich früher seine
praktikantin und der arme reichelt hatte
noch mehr zu tun in dieser woche gleich
danach musste er will smiths verteidigen
der am wochenende zeigte dass man sich
gar nicht mehr entscheiden muss zwischen
alfermann und frauenversteher man kann
beides haben erst haut man den moderator
eine runter später bei der dankesrede
holtmann als ob es kein bier mehr gibt
und den oscar kriegt man noch obendrauf
glückwunsch was ist denn jetzt männlich
viele männer glauben immer noch es kommt
darauf an die größte rakete in der
garage zu haben für mich wäre nicht
allein die parkplatzsuche solange wir
männer immer noch alles als
schwanzvergleich sehen müssen wir noch
viel lernen aber es gibt hoffnung wenn
jeder jeden tag nur ein prozent
wie war das noch mal so und wenn du
jeden tag ein prozent rein steckt und
dann die arbeit ist hast du am ende des
jahres 3800 prozent das heißt du bist
fast
38 mal besser als sein jetziger zustand
wo 38 mal besser ich konnte die rechnung
jetzt nicht ganz nachvollziehen aber ich
glaube ihm einfach immerhin ist er ein
mann
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
auslasten abo da